my name is farhana musarat you all can
call me farhana i'm the program
coordinator for the omics logic lsu
biomed summer programs i'm basically a
molecular virologist and working as a
postdoctoral researcher at lsu baton
rouge at the school of veterinary
science
and i will be assisting mostly the lbrn
and lsu members with registration and
any other issues that that they might
have
so these are the courses that we are
offering for the summer and elia already
described these courses
and
the question is who is eligible for this
course and the answer is it's uh
actually everyone
so this course is open to all
and um
anybody uh which is who are in lsu
usa or any other countries in the world
can take these courses and the courses
are available for a fee
however we are offering this free
registration for a limited number of
people
and the criteria is you have to be a
member of lbrn
or lsu school of veterinary medicine or
navy
lsu campuses members
are welcome to take the course
also
however the course will not be free for
them
so how do we register for the courses i
have been getting a lot of emails about
registration process
and i need i think i need to explain it
very clearly
so the registration process includes two
steps
one is the pre-registration
and the other is the registration
so the pre-registration process
includes
uh
opening an account
in the
lion omixlogic
portal which is the educational portal
and all your course materials will be
accessible there and before that you
have already registered for the program
in the edu.omicslogic.com
lsu biomed
so once you register here once you click
the register for the program here
you actually have
submitted the application to us and when
you open the account and create an
account and update your profile just
what
chaps and helia showed
you already
are in our system
however
for lsu and lvrn members only we need
additional steps to complete the
registration this step is not applicable
for navy
so for lsu and lbrn members only
for to complete the registration you
have to make sure that you have an
account in the ilab
so once you have created an account
there
you will have a login information
username and password and when you log
in here
you will see a drop down menu here on
the left top corner
you click here and then you will see the
core facilities
and then you will select the cedar core
facilities and services on the left
after that
you have to click on the
request services on the right side top
corner
so
after that you will see
training modules sections where you will
see all the names of the courses that we
are offering for summer
so in this training module with the red
asterisk mark you have to write down
what are the courses that you are
interested in
so you have to write down the names of
the courses in this red in this white
section
so once you are done
you you will see here a fun number
section
but you don't have to put any number
here
since the lsu and lb lbrn members will
be sponsored by us
so what you can write here
is just write whether you are from lsu
lbrn or lsu school of veterinary
medicine
and then just click the submit request
to core
and that is how you will complete your
registration
so if you have any other questions
regarding the registration process
please don't hesitate to contact me my
email address is i'm going to write in
the chat section
it's fmusa r1
at
lsu.edu
so i will try to answer any other
questions that you have or
you can write it in the chat section or
shoot me an email later on
and we will be happy to
answer and try to help out with the
registration process
so that's all helium